[Music]
you see the earth from space it changes
you it changes your relationship with
this planet with humanity
i really want you to come with me would
you are you serious i am
i think it would be meaningful i have my
brother there
in this instagram video blue origin ceo
jeff bezos
shocked the world when he announced that
he and his brother would be aboard the
company's first human spaceflight
scheduled for july 20th
if the suborbital flight of new shepard
is a success it will propel blue origin
ahead of competitors
setting the stage for the next era of
commercial human space travel
i want to move out into the solar system
i want my grandchildren's grandchildren
to be in that world a world pioneering
an exploration
expansion throughout the solar system
the launch of new shepard comes at a key
moment for blue origin which has faced
setbacks in other high profile parts of
its business
here's how blue origin blasted ahead of
its competition and what its inaugural
passenger flight means for the company
in the race to launch tourism flights
into space blue origin's main competitor
virgin galactic has been in the lead we
are the first to the commercial
spaceship companies to
put people into space in may 2021
richard branson's space venture
successfully launched its third crude
space flight three
two one release release release
a feat blue origin has yet to achieve
but this is where bezos company hopes to
inch out ahead
the new shepard launch in july will have
at least one paying passenger
something virgin galactic has never done
it's a key marker
doug cameron has covered the aerospace
industry for over 30 years
they've won contracts they've won
government and
military deals they've developed rockets
but a lot of it is still
just that in development so this is
something which they've actually
set out with an objective and achieve if
everything goes as planned
passengers will spend a few minutes
experiencing microgravity
above the karman line the altitude where
space begins
and the cost to be on this historic
flight isn't cheap
in june blue origin held a charity
auction for a ticket to join bezos into
suborbital space
sold 28 million dollars to number 107
there is ultimately a perhaps a
multi-billion dollar
business to be built and taking people
to the edge of space and maybe beyond
but as blue origin plans its first space
tourism flight
larger parts of its business have been
struggling recently the space venture
has faced scrutiny
for losing a couple of high-profile
government contracts
in april spacex beat out blue origin in
a bid to build a lunar lander for nasa
nasa officials said it chose spacex
because its bid
fit within the agency's budget blue
origin it's
pushing back and that and it's hopeful
that more money can be found
and that it can get that kind of big
government contract which can help
fund future vehicles and technology
going forward nasa's lunar lander wasn't
the only big ticket deal that blue
origin has missed out on
in august 2020 bezos company lost a
multi-billion dollar air force contract
to spacex and united launch alliance
industry insiders were not surprised the
pentagon had previously indicated
that it would put a high value on the
track record of each company in the
running
and spacex and united launch alliance
both had a longer history of military
launches
that blue origin did not recently bezos
company has also faced development
delays
its mammoth new glenn rocket was
originally slated for completion this
year but
has been pushed back into late 2022.
they obviously have
a number of technical hurdles for for
the broader business that they still
have to cross
every executive and engineer involved in
the space business will say that it's
it's hard
it's tricky you're playing with physics
here and and physics is a
very hard task master but aside from a
rocky start
blue origin space tourism program has
run smoother than some other parts of
the business
new shepard's first first launch
didn't go well it blew up they've had 15
successful ones
as well as tests of other other parts of
the system since then
and the road to launch new shepard has
been successful in part
due to its funding blue origin has bezos
financial backing
and he is one of the wealthiest men in
the world bezos has funneled as much as
roughly 1 billion dollars a year into
the space venture to fund his cosmic
vision
it's one earth i want to go on this
flight because
it's a thing i've wanted to do all my
life
it's an adventure bezos is even stepping
away from his role as ceo of amazon
one of the largest companies in the
world in part to focus on blue origin
if blue origin's rocket lifts off on
schedule it will be a big win for the
company
the important thing about this first
launch is uh
it it'll be you know potentially the the
first time that blue origin
has achieved something it said it was
going to do that everyone can grasp
they've
put people in space but competitor
virgin galactic isn't far behind
in august 2020 the company signaled
plans to launch its own tourism flights
in 2021
so if it's a success the launch of new
shepard would signal the start of the
next era of space tourism
not only for blue origin but for the
larger space industry as well